Trascrizione: Aurora Barbizzi
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Allora, come vi sentite?
Certo che la musica è potente,
è una forza, è un’energia straordinaria,
È dinamica, io amo dire che lo è.
Dinamica è una parola
che arriva dal greco dynamis,
una forza che riesce a
spostare tutti gli eventi,
sposta il nostro stato d’animo.
Lo porta a destra, sinistra, in alto,
in basso, è una potenza.
E voi sapete perché?
Ve la siete mai fatta questa domanda?
Questa sera vi dico una cosa
che pochi forse vi hanno mai detto.
La musica ha cinque dimensioni.
Le prime le conosciamo.
Partiamo dalla prima.
La prima è lo spazio.
Lo spazio in un rigo pentagramma,
lo troviamo in senso verticale,
una nota prima, le note
in senso verticale, dal basso all’alto.
Qui abbiamo lo spazio.
La seconda dimensione è il tempo,
in senso orizzontale, in un pentagramma,
le note una dopo l’altra in successione.
La terza dimensione è la profondità.
Ossia, l’interpretazione
di quello spazio temporale.
In musica lo si troverebbe con dei segni.
Siamo abituati a vedere la freccia,
il crescendo, il diminuendo, il pedale,
il forte, il piano, tutta una serie
di segni che aiutano il musicista
a interpretare il brano.
La cosa interessante di questa
terza dimensione è che è soggettiva.
Cioè, mentre la prima e la seconda
sono oggettive,
cioè le note sono quelle e quelle restano.
Nella terza dimensione
l’interpretazione è affidata
all’esecutore.
Se prendiamo un brano e lo affidiamo a
100 esecutori diversi,
100 musicisti diversi,
avremo 100 profondità diverse,
100 interpretazioni diverse.
La 4.ª dimensione, che è molto importante
e troppo spesso sottovalutata, purtroppo,
è il senso dell'armonia.
Vale a dire che una serie di note,
accordi, moduli, intrecci musicali,
piuttosto che altri, possono generare
in noi un senso di gioia, serenità,
spensieratezza piuttosto che di tristezza,
angoscia, senso cupo della vita.
Ecco, il senso dell’armonia
è fondamentale,
è una chiave importante nella nostra vita
e in verità lo troviamo
in tantissimi campi.
Basti pensare ai canoni di bellezza
e di estetica nel mondo dell'arte.
Se pensiamo alla natura, all’architettura,
abbiamo la sezione aurea.
Avete presente questo senso?
Questo archetipo di bellezza?
Di proporzione?
E quindi l’abbiamo anche, io sono
qui per questo, in musica.
Tanti compositori nel passato hanno
fatto uso di questa dimensione.
Anche quelli contemporanei non scherzano.
Io vorrei fare un esempio su tutti.
Il canone di Pachelbel.
Lo conoscete, vero?
Ecco, quello è uno straordinaria esempio.
Pensate che dopo 350 anni,
è ancora la musica più amata,
ascoltata e interpretata
in tutto il mondo.
Ma qual è il motivo?
Il motivo è semplice,
che dentro ognuno di noi,
è innato il senso della bellezza, della
proporzione, della sezione aurea.
Ecco che quando un’opera d’arte arriva,
quando un pensiero musicale
tocca il nostro cuore, passa da noi.
Trova le porte aperte, perché noi stessi
siamo in sezione aurea.
Noi siamo bellezza dentro.
E questo spiega il motivo per cui alcune
musiche ti piacciono subito
alla prima volta.
E non escono più.
E per lo stesso motivo.
Altre bussano, ma non entreranno mai.
Perché noi, noi siamo bellezza
e ci meritiamo bellezza.
E adesso passiamo alla 5.ª
e ultima dimensione.
Questa forse è proprio dimenticata.
Ed è particolare, molto strana,
perché è difficile da scrivere.
Ne è prova il fatto
che il mondo accademico
non l’ha ancora contemplata.
In realtà, la 5.ª dimensione appartiene
più all’anima, sfiora la spiritualità,
è difficilmente spiegabile.
La 5.ª dimensione chiede all’artista
chiede al musicista
un grande atto di umiltà,
che lo porta alla consapevolezza
che la musica non è sua.
Non gli appartiene.
La musica è qualcosa
di straordinariamente grande,
di cui lui è solo un amministratore.
È l’amministratore delegato
di un potere più grande di lui.
E questa è una grande consapevolezza.
Sennò c’è il rischio che qualcuno
pensi che la musica è affar suo,
e fa quello che vuole,
ma può fare anche danni.
Allora potremmo scrivere invece che
“la musica ci salva”,
“salviamoci dalla musica”.
E questo è un rischio.
Ecco, quando io ho preso
consapevolezza di questo.
Anni fa, dopo aver cavalcato
diversi teatri
per proporre la mia musica,
le mie composizioni.
Ho...
Ho fatto....
Un cambio di paradigma.
Ho fatto la mia rivoluzione o
la mia piccola apocalisse.
Ho preso...
Un pianoforte a coda, pesante,
ma ricco di energia.
E ho cominciato a portarlo in giro per le
strade, le piazze, le città , le montagne,
i mari, le spiagge e ovunque
ci fossero persone
che non erano lì
per ascoltare un pianoforte.
Ed è questo.
È cambio di paradigma.
Ora in teatro è facile, la gente va, voi
andate, pagate pure il biglietto perché
andate incontro alla musica,
andate ad ascoltare la musica.
Lì fuori è il contrario, è la musica
che viene incontro a te.
È la potenza della musica.
E quando questa musica è carica di energia
ha tutte le sue dimensioni.
E riesce ad accendere in noi
la fiamma del cambiamento.
La capacità di cambiare paradigma.
Che significa avere il coraggio,
di rivedere tutte le nostre certezze,
le nostre convinzioni,
le nostre vecchie strade.
E la musica è la compagna migliore.
Per un cambio di prospettiva
e per un nuovo inizio.